hello everybody and welcome to my top
five money-making methods for freeo play
so in this guide I can show you five
methods um some of them can reach
upwards of 350k an hour uh which is
pretty good for freet to play
considering there's not a lot of good
methods uh yeah so let's just jump right
into it here at number five is uh
crafting gold amulets unrung uh it's a
really easy method all that is required
is to have eight crafting you will be
getting about
125k GP an hour and while it's not the
highest one it is really easy to AFK
this method and I like it cuz it gives
you 35k approximately uh crafting XP
every hour uh which is really nice
especially for freet to play um so
basically to get here you just go to
lumbridge and go right across the bridge
into the AL desert uh go south and
eventually hit a bank and uh basically
you're just going to be withdrawing the
gold bar from the bank uh running to the
furnace and crafting them into gold
amulets unstrung and all you need is a
amulet mold which you can get in Alid or
at the Grand exchange depending on the
prices you can sometimes do uh make
sapphire rings as well for a good amount
of money sometimes is a bit more uh but
the gold animats have been more
consistent and um you don't need this
High crafting level for them and at
number four is uh telegrabbing the wines
of zamak from the chaos Temple uh pretty
easy method all you require is 33 magic
for T grab and uh it can net you about
215k an hour and and just a little bit
of magic
XP and yeah so to get here you're just
going to teleport to falor or walk and
you're just going to go up north kind of
hug the wall on the left and eventually
get to the chaos Temple uh so just go in
there you'll see all the uh monks around
all you're going to do is use the
telegrab spell on the wine of Zam and
basically just repeat that until you
have a full inventory uh the wine
responds about every 30 seconds or so uh
when you have the full inventory just
teleport back to falor and then just run
back and at number three uh we have
buying room packs from the magic shop
this you have no requirements to do all
you really require is some starting cash
uh because your money will go quickly uh
I would recommend if you can get at
least 500k to start but you really don't
need a specific amount this method can
net you like 250 to 300K an hour uh
really depends on how contested the
shops are I prefer to go to Agatha's
Rune shop in Port Sim as opposed to the
one in verac I think that's her name
anyway
um but yeah to get there I mean ports
Rim just go south of falor until you hit
it basically and what you're going to do
is just make sure you have all the money
you want with you uh you're going to buy
out all of the elemental runes so like
fire air earth and water and also the
death runes uh and the chaos runes you
can buy but it requires quite a bit of
money to actually be able to afford a
bunch of them um I prefer to buy the
wind or the fire r runes as they do sell
quicker um but at the same time by
having a different combination of the
runes you will get around the buy and
limit on the grand exchange a lot easier
and so yeah basically just buy up the
runes I wouldn't go past they start with
60 or sorry 80 stock I wouldn't go past
the 60 Mark um without just hopping to
another world after you bought the packs
you're just going to spam click on them
to open them up you can click on one and
they'll open slowly but it'll just be
way slower it's not worth it so just
click on them as quickly as you can and
then go buy more so once you bought all
the runes that you want uh just go to
the gr exchange and make sure you sell
them for the high price which is five
currently um or else you won't be making
any money uh the death runes you can
sell for the average price if you want
uh or you can just hold out for more
money as well and coming in at number
two is uh a very similar method but
you're going to be buying feathers and
fishing bait from the fishing shop
instead uh so it's really easy to get to
again there's no requirement
H you'll be getting somewhere between
250 and 300K an hour if you're
focusing um yeah so to get here very
similar just go to fador run totally
South it's in part Port Sim uh but this
time we're going to go to the fishing
shop the only reason this is ranked
higher is because you don't really have
to hop worlds for this method uh what
you're going to do is just buy 10 of
each of the packs close the store spam
click them all and open them up and they
restock quickly enough that you might as
well just wait and buy more more buy
them around when they're back up to I
think they stock up to 80 again so we're
going to buy them between 75 and 80 um
and yeah so it's really easy again it is
quite click intensive uh but you don't
have to hop world you're just going to
spam click them open and uh buy more
just bring as much money as you think
you want to buy in them and then when
you go to the Grand exchange uh makes
sell you sell the uh the feathers for
three and the fishing bait for four and
they all sell pretty quickly
and at number one the best free-to-play
money-making method I would have to say
is Telly grabbing nature runes in the
wilderness so this method again just
requires telegrab so 33 magic and um you
can get actually upwards of 400k an hour
probably around the 350 Mark and uh
between 15 and 20K magic X every hour um
the problem is it is a bit risky there
are pees it's really deep in the
wilderness uh but it's you're not really
risking a whole lot and it is worth it
just for how much money you can make so
to get here it's a pretty long Trek H
just GNA start in barck you're going to
go the north exit and uh go along the
Eastern side of the Wilderness just keep
you in way up it's in level 40
Wilderness keep going north keep going
north and eventually uh you'll see a
greater demon and they're just two
nature Rune spots they're on an
island and uh what you're going to do is
you take the air sty with you and uh law
runes as well as a Teleport back to
barck when you're done so you're just
going to cast telegrab on the two law
Rune spawns one's four and one's three
so you get the seven law runes and um
sorry the seven nature runes then you're
going to hop to another world I did this
for about an hour and it was not that
not that many people there I saw a
couple PS but you are focusing to do
this anyway so it's pretty easy to avoid
them and your world hopping all the time
anyway now I got about 300K an hour by
going back every half an hour uh I tried
it again where I just stayed there I
brought a bunch of runes it's a little
riskier but I made upwards of 400k an
hour um so whatever you want to risk
it's up to you but it is one of the best
if not the best money-making methods in
free to play right now and yeah so those
are my top five money-making methods for
freeo play I hope you guys enjoyed and
maybe learned something uh if you
enjoyed I would appreciate if you left
the video like and uh if you want to see
more just uh hit that subscribe button
all right I'll see you guys next time